this is one of the places but I seem to
disagree with Richard Dawkins whenever
you disagree with Richard Dawkins the
chances are you're wrong
Dawkins seems to think that the state
can come in and have the authority to
decide truth or not truth he seems to
think that the teaching of evolution is
really really important and that the
state should do it I think issed or
eclis we see them we replace religion
with the state things go way way badly
ah I believe and I may be wrong on this
but I think that individuals care
desperately about education I think
there's a condescending quality that has
to do with we have to educate the masses
because we know better and I believe
that all the tools are in place for
people to learn on their own the whole
idea that the state has to bestow upon
children enlightenment may be outdated I
think that Moore's law and the way Wi-Fi
is proliferating and how cheap things
are getting and how far the level of
poverty is coming up I mean people who
are considered to be in a poverty the
poverty level in the u.s. I have cell
phones and I'm not saying that any sort
of they're not really poor
they really are wicked poor and terribly
poor but they do have cell phones and
information is there an education is
there and I think that education is
going to come from the web I mean my
children go to a fancy-ass expensive
private school but I see them going on
the internet and learning more than they
do in that that environment I would like
to think
that people are overwhelmingly good and
that charity works and we will help each
other and I think that the image of a
libertarian state being a huge disparity
of income doesn't seem completely
accurate the disparity that we have now
is not coming business they pretend that
the Bush years were a year of years of
no regulation and freedom and kind of
libertarian there's no evidence of that
what we have now is not rich people who
are working outside the law but rich
people who are gaming the system you
know all the problems we've had have not
been that they're not regulated but that
they're working the regulation in their
benefit we've had people that have made
huge mistakes and then are rewarded for
it I mean we've done huge bailouts of
people that should have crashed and
burned and they make this deal with you
and I don't think it's ever stated this
way although it may be it may actually
be stated this way where they kind of
say if you play into the system and if
you let us regulate you and if we let
you do what you what if you do what we
want we will guarantee you won't go out
of business
we will boy you up we will help you
we'll give you tax breaks we'll do all
of this and there's a view of
libertarianism that it is somehow
everybody wants what happened during the
Bush administration to continue and more
so every libertarian I know hated the
Bush administration it did not seem fair
it did not seem small government it was
not small government it was people
getting in bed with the government to do
this phony crony capitalism without the
government watching over holding on to
things and too big to fail things just
go up and down and rich people take more
of a rollercoaster ride than poor people
my point of view on libertarianism is
first let's stop the things we all agree
need to be stopped
let's stop as my partner teller
says let's stop spending money we don't
have to kill people we don't know for
reasons we don't understand
let's just stop killing people that's
really expensive and Bush and Obama did
a lot of that then let's stop all the
bailing out of rich people let's stop
all the we've got to help people get
jobs by giving money to these rich
people planning on trickle-down from the
government let's stop that you know as
as Harry Brown the libertarian candidate
from 20 years ago used to say we spend
all this money on tobacco subsidies and
all this money educating people not to
smoke
let's just stop one of them we don't
care which one to begin with just stop
one of them and I think then we Whittle
it down and then you know you can make
your argument that we still need
education that we still need libraries
that we still need infrastructure and
you probably win with me the mistake we
make with libertarianism I think is that
we start by saying let's stop the
government from doing really stupid
stuff and people come back with the
argument saying so you don't want
bridges and you go okay can we argue
about bridges after we're out of
Afghanistan we argue about bridges after
we've stopped killing people in Texas
for crimes can we argue about bridges
after there's no one in prison for
marijuana possession and use nobody in
prison for prostitution
can we once we get all that done can we
then have the argument about bridges can
we just stop the stuff that big
government's doing that we really know
is bad
you